hi guys so don't get too excited because
this isn't going to be a crazy humorous
video or some fun adventure but what it
is is a little thank you to everyone
that's watching this video right now um
i love you and i have a fun
little
surprise um something that i'm extremely
excited about as a lot of you guys know
i'm from pittsburgh and this month
pittsburgh magazine did a little article
on me
so i'm so excited because well i love
pittsburgh i love going home to visit
and
i'm just speechless i'm reaching
into your
into your homes huge thank you to
jonathan who wrote the article we sat
down a few months ago and and chatted
about everything from why i do this to
um oh
what i took my senior picture with sneak
peek
seeing your picture right there
links in the sidebar if you want to see
what the actual picture looks like very
very funny
and a big thanks to alex who was there
the whole time shooting some crazy video
of
well the crazy photo shoot that i got
myself into
and laura who shot the photos did an
awesome job as you guys also know i'm a
huge ketchup fan
so there's one photo
i was laying in some ketchup packets
here's me and my ketchup obsession
all the links will be in the sidebar or
on my blog at igesteen.com that you can
just kind of click and figure it out if
you want to buy a copy too they have a
little link on their website too if you
want to if you want to get an extra one
um
yeah okay that's it
okay see you guys later i gotta go work
on a secret little halloween video
excited
you